look what we found I think we found the
winner down there oh my god what's gonna
happen tell me I can't do it in three
hours Nina loves rats it actually just
kind of scary
all right next up we're going to hit the
Tower of London
we're decided to go inside the Tower of
London to go up top note London power
great mate London Bridge we're going up
the bridge that's over the river I've
never been we decided we're gonna go
sometimes
don't look down don't look down Dina
yeah you gotta walk on top of Vanina
go walk on top the whole point you gotta
walk on top not next to it go you don't
need to hold on okay go you don't need
to hold on keep going in the middle look
down Nina it actually is kind of scary
go to the middle no you got to lean up a
leaf hashtag believe go go to the middle
go go go and briefs your fear you got it
in the middle let go keep going keep
going okay now look down and walk look
walk you got it
sweating all there's another bridge
there's another glass floor Nina is your
chance
well she's doing it she's doing it well
all right how do you feel Nina scared
okay Nina conquered a few today good job
high five - Nina
all right we're up the know we're still
in the bridge but we're done with the
top oh there's a glass you can see out
see the die for the people you can see
up their pants
alright good we're gonna celebrate
Nina's active courage with Evan getting
the Frappuccino it's a quality
celebration Nina might get a tea perfect
Starbucks here we come
so we're right next to the Tower of
London and we're gonna see if we can get
in I'm pretty sure you can't bring
drinks inside so means I have to delay
my Starbucks we have to delay the Nina
courage celebration but when you wait
for something and you have the patience
it makes the reward that much more sweet
so they're closing in about an hour they
recommend not going in because it will
take three hours I don't think it would
take us three hours we tend to hustle
through we could probably get it done in
an hour it's almost a challenge to do it
in an hour
it's almost egging me on this say you
don't think I could do it in an hour you
don't think I could do it in yeah
I've been through it's okay it's nice
I've been have been tell me I can't do
it in three hours tell me I can't do
something I love hearing no it just
means yes okay but start like sign whoo
all right there it is
come on Starbucks give me my vlog
sponsorship let's go believe nation you
got to know somebody at Starbucks it's
going to sponsor this vlog lots of free
promotion here time to get a Frappuccino
all right come to the spice fat for me
camera LT for Nina Cheers
hmm that's good it's very good
Nina also got a salted caramel cookie
that was it good
are you trying which ones better what
you want me to try oh yeah you don't get
that add to the Starbucks board Nina's
upset didn't write Chinese on the board
she went to added like where's the
marker they don't put that for you to
write
okay Starbucks employees right then just
go talk to the manager and say listen
you gotta add some Chinese to the wall
just for Nina represent in China okay
next up we're gonna go to the Brick Lane
market it's a bit of a hike from here
but we're gonna get a good walk on
another little kind of local market area
people selling their stuff and we're
gonna explore I've never been there
either so be a fun little journey and
see here we go house drink our drinks
please do not beat the birds as it
encourages rats and other vermin
Nina loves rats what Kate believed
nation if you know what flower this is
leave in the comments it will make Nina
very happy check it out Canada flag
representing I'm excited
you're either as beautiful or as ugly as
you believe you are you define your
beauty that's not a power anyone can
have over you hashtag believe I love it
all right setting at hungry and you know
Street certainly get tired so we're
looking for a traditional British pub
because we haven't been the one yet so
we may have just found one
it says traditional pub on the outside
which is good there's even going in this
place is called
the Chamberlain let's see what they have
or leaving the Chamberlain we're really
trying to find a place that has bangers
and mash which is sausage and mashed
potatoes hopefully we'll find one if we
don't then we'll settle for something
else but we're not ready to throw in the
towel just yet the hunt continues
so after three searches we finally found
a place Nicholson's
that has where is it where is it classic
Maine [ __ ]
old spot sausages served with mashed
potatoes they don't call it bangers and
mash
but it's sausages with mashed potatoes
that qualifies bangers and mash okay st.
Paul's Cathedral is up ahead there we're
gonna head to the church and see if we
see anything with bangers and mash along
the way
if not we can come back to try this
place what do you think Nina that's the
plane all right let's see official plan
look what we found I think we found the
winner down there this is the British
tradition finish work go to the pub grab
a drink outside and everybody does it
that's cool nice social thing so we
stock some local Brits here those guys
that qualified as bangers and mash and
said yes this is your traditional thing
as mash so we found our place exciting
church and they eat [ __ ] Church
enemies
that was a very old woman sound you made
mean as you sat down
all right so they're closed
we just got turned away whether that
security guard behind me makes me want
to kind of pad Nina for him some kind of
distraction so I could jump in film
felting for you guys just a little bit a
little bit
okay well it's closed so it's bangers
and mash time for Nina bangers and mash
time
all right you found the bangs to match
the fact that ye olde Watling get some
dinner
but most people here are just having a
beer and they take it outside and
socialize if you want to then you come
to this other room where there's few
people but they bring you the fluids
excited to try this stuff and you never
Vegas of mash so I'm having the mango
IPA and say cheers
this is the lightest year I think I've
ever had it's pretty light it's got some
mango that's cut I don't know if this
the mango has got some fruitiness very
hoppy aftertaste so there's a big
aftertaste it's good I like it
good job Nicholson's oh this place is
called Nicholson's very very excited
I'll take some sorry
thank you sour cream go go go near to go
no mana tree all right
Nina's had some good food today that
makes me very happy
any unit right oh you feeding me
the grain is very different right we
just came out we finished our last
dinner in London how do you feel like
good satisfied not too full
I feel like good - we snuck a little
fudge in - hi - Lina had one crazy hot
jalapeno pepper and then she's like do
your face yeah freaking at 15 and she's
like give me fudge
give me fudge like what anyway so we
pulled out a fudge and then she went to
the bathroom and I snuck three pieces of
flesh three yeah I think I think three I
think three it's okay it's good fudge
holy cow and we needed a dessert they
didn't have dessert there I would have
had like a something dessert pudding or
something anyway we are going to
make our way back there maybe buses that
are still running for us a catch it's a
long walk it's like a two-hour walk back
which mean that kind of wants to do but
I imagine you're crashing halfway
through and then I'm in trouble so we're
gonna see if the bus we can catch it
otherwise subway get back home pack for
tomorrow we leave and watch some agents
of shield the last episode ended on a
really big oh my god what's gonna happen
so Nina's been thinking about it all day
I need some fudge and some Doritos and
chips champagne that's a night wake up
early tomorrow morning get back all
right we got our bus yeah blue bus oh
it's the perfect one - yeah good timing
I love it when things work out no
arrangement hasn't read no rain
we found the great pub we
got the last bus one of the last buses
that came or waited like two minutes but
our bus is the perfect bus there are two
options we've got the better one
all right we're off the bus the rain is
coming down just a little tiny bit it's
eight o'clock it was supposed to start
at 6:00 so super grateful that we had a
nice entire day really of no rain so
Nina's gonna never get us home
gonna do our thing relax and get ready
for our departure tomorrow I think we'll
end the vlog there thank you guys for
tuning in we believe in you we hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever take care guys have a great
weekend